otro desafío del nuevo quinquenio en
pronuncia el respeto del derecho a la
vivienda es lo que pidieron los
manifestantes que se reunieron frente a
las sedes de los partidos de los dos
candidatos finalistas
y hablan del poder adquisitivo del poder
adquisitivo pero hoy para gran parte de
los franceses es el 50 o 60 por ciento
de los ingresos que se destina a la
vivienda son personas que trabajan
personas que recogen nuestra basura
personas que cuidan nuestros mayores
personas que trabajan en hospitales que
hacen la limpieza que reponen las
estanterías personas cuyos hijos están
en el colegio de mis hijos no puedo
mirar les y decirle bueno no es tan malo
dormir en tu coche o dormir en un hotel
social al hotel social no más culpa no
en teoría la ley de la luz de 2007 es
reconoce un derecho a la vivienda para
cualquier residente de francia que no
puede acceder a ella por sus propios
medios pero el país cuenta con al menos
300.000 personas sin hogar
os pedimos que se respeten las leyes y
los derechos que protegen a las personas
sin hogar el derecho al alojamiento
hasta el realojamiento pedimos respecto
de los derechos y la aplicación de las
leyes
decenas de inmigrantes sin documentos
ocuparon locales desocupados en el
distrito 9 de parís para exigir el
cumplimiento de este derecho
nos apetece decir la prueba está en
ucrania es decir es posible establecer
todo un sistema de alojamiento dar
papeles a todos dar transporte gratuito
a todos son cosas por la que llevamos
luchando 40 años 50 años y francia lo ha
hecho en 15 días en sus pancartas se
podía leer no al racismo o las vidas de
los migrantes importan